[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
más romero sala ya está con nosotros en
el estudio mar bien venía muy buena
mañana del lunes vamos a volver a hablar
de las vacunas contra el cubit 19 un
nuevo estudio vuelve a vincular con las
alteraciones en el ciclo menstrual
lumbar buenos días raúl efectivamente lo
nombramos también porque es uno de los
estudios más grandes hecho hasta la
fecha sabes que le estamos dando
seguimiento a este tema desde hace ya
varias semanas repasemos muy brevemente
estas cifras 42 por ciento de las
personas encuestadas reportaron haber
tenido un sangrado más abundante en
contra a 43 por ciento dijeron no haber
sentido ningún cambio especialmente se
reportaron más alteraciones en personas
que habían tenido diagnósticos previos
ginecológicos y también por ejemplo las
mujeres con endometriosis y también en
personas que habían parado tener la
regla les volvió el ciclo menstrual por
ejemplo personas menopáusicas o personas
que estaban en tratamientos hormonales
de reafirmación de género para analizar
todas estas cifras también qué
implicaciones tiene estamos como cada
lunes con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor cuéntenos
las cifras de este estudio son al menos
impactantes sin embargo queremos
preguntarle son suficientes para mostrar
una relación de causalidad es decir
asegurar que las vacunas son las que
están provocando estas alteraciones
definitivamente no se puede relacionar
con causalidad recordemos que este es un
estudio que se llama descriptivo es
decir busca a través de una encuesta de
escribir una situación que le llama la
atención a los investigadores genera
planteamientos tendencias o preguntas
pero no afirmas relaciones ni causalidad
lo que se ve y los las investigadas son
muy claras es decir que hay una
tendencia sin embargo no puede
establecer que sea directamente por la
vacuna puede ser lo que se llama un
sesgo de recolección es decir que las
personas que han tenido alteraciones
hayan contestado más la encuesta que las
personas que no hayan tenido
alteraciones y que eso puedan modificar
los resultados lo que sí plantea es una
pregunta válida para hacer estudios
posteriores pero con la información que
tenemos ahora no podemos establecer
causalidad vacunas con alteraciones
menstruales ahora doctor digamos porque
se puede haber pasado por alto un
posible efecto secundario o tan habitual
no lo sé ha pasado por alto de todo esto
se ha registrado lo que llama la
atención las investigadoras es que como
vieron esos resultados quisieron indagar
y ampliar en un gran número de mujeres
realmente es un gran número de encuestas
con qué sé que poner a la manifestación
sobre su alteración en el ciclo
menstrual pero también es claro que hoy
como tal también produce alteraciones en
el ciclo menstrual que incluso puede ser
más prolongadas que lo mismo que se ha
revisado en los estudios entonces no es
que no se haya evaluado este efecto
adverso simplemente que en este estudio
se muestra a través de una encuesta que
es altamente prevalente y que llama la
atención a los investigadores para
generar preguntas para estudios que sean
de mayor validez científica
sí sin embargo claramente estos estudios
han hecho posteriormente a que varias
mujeres reportaron eso y no lo
recogieran los estudios de seguridad de
las vacunas también porque muchas veces
reportan pues problemas hasta los siete
días después de la inoculación cosa que
no siempre alcanza a reportar por
ejemplo casos o cambios como los ciclos
menstruales para puntualizar queríamos
preguntarle usted mismo estaba hablando
posibles tendencias todavía sin poder
hablar de esa causalidad sin embargo
esas preguntas que se reportan
precisamente de este vínculo posible que
hipótesis estamos manejando o qué
hipótesis está manejando en la comunidad
científica como posibilidad para
explicar que la respuesta inmune por
ejemplo de las vacunas de este
provocando estas alteraciones
la misma activación de la respuesta
inmune que generan las vacunas o que
genera el coi también producen y se
pueden relacionar con esta alteración
del ciclo menstrual recordemos que el
ciclo menstrual de todas formas es un
ciclo que se altera por muchas
patologías enfermedades crónicas las
personas que más sufren de coke ya hemos
visto que tiene enfermedades crónicas no
controladas y el hecho de tener una
diabetes no controlada de tener
alteraciones en su sistema endotelial en
o afectación del sistema en total pues
hacen más propensos a los cambios
menstruales independientemente del coi
por eso es hay que poder discernir entre
si es por la enfermedad por la vacuna
relacionado con el código o relacionado
exclusivamente con una vacuna o con cual
vacuna la hipótesis más valiosa es la
activación del sistema inmune que altere
el ciclo menstrual pero como lo
hablábamos mal puede ser por la vacuna
pero también por la enfermedad
claro doctores digamos que si estas
alteraciones son temporales se pregunte
entonces por la seguridad de la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 sigue siendo seguro
esta vacuna
absolutamente seguras no tiene las
mismas investigadores de el del estudio
son muy empáticas en decir que el hecho
que no sean infrecuentes no son
riesgosas y no ponen en alteración la
salud femenina las vacunas son seguras
son seguras tanto en las mujeres incluso
en las mujeres embarazadas en los niños
en las adolescentes ya son más de 10 mil
12 mil millones de personas que han
recibido la inoculación con una por más
de un año donde se siguen haciendo los
seguimientos lo que comentaba más de los
efectos adversos tempranos que se hace
una semana pero el seguimiento en
fármaco de lancia se sigue haciendo
incluso años después para mirar si hay
algo otro efecto algún otro efecto en la
vacuna y no se ha demostrado las vacunas
son seguras para las mujeres son seguras
en el embarazo son seguras en los
adolescentes y si no se han vacunado se
deben vacunar sí por supuesto y recordar
como siempre los millones de vidas que
han salvado ya pues poder inmunizarnos
contra el cubit 19 sin embargo para
terminar hay muchas mujeres que han
sentido ese vacío de información
alrededor de precisamente las
alteraciones del ciclo menstrual
por ejemplo pues tener ese vacío de
información ha podido alimentar
discursos anti vacunas precisamente
entonces quería preguntarle cuáles son
los siguientes pasos que debemos seguir
cuáles son las respuestas que tenemos
que obtener para que haya esta
tranquilidad alrededor de precisamente
la seguridad de las vacunas
hay un hecho fundamental el coi no
altera la menstruación la enfermedad por
coke e incluso alteraciones muestrales
que pueden ser crónicas prolongadas el
joven preguntado se ha relacionado
también con estas alteraciones es decir
que tener cohetes es mucho más grande
desde el ciclo menstrual que lo que se
está relacionando con la alteración por
la vacuna del court lo segundo es que
las vacunas como hemos visto han sido
extensamente probadas y han sido
suficientemente seguras para no
interrumpir la vacunación en ningún
grupo de edad ni en género y lo tercero
que es muy importante hay que seguir
construyendo evidencia una cosa son las
opiniones y otra cosa es la verdad la
verdad se construye con evidencia con
hechos científicos y lo que plantean los
investigadores es un poco más de
estudios para poder puntualizar que el
grupo de personas por ejemplo mujeres
con endometriosis o con alteraciones
menstruales qué tipo de vacunas y en
donde se podría hacer una intervención
pero el mensaje central es que las
vacunas son seguras para las mujeres y
todos debemos seguirnos vacunados
así es doctor como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información en este
tema tan interesante entonces que queja
a millones de personas que tienen este
ciclo menstrual doctor como siempre
gracias gracias también marc pasamos a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día